Millie Bobby Brown thinks there's only
one way stranger things connect as she
said 11 needs to die and Maya Hawk feels
very mixed about whether or not Robin
should get a girlfriend in season 5. you
have your thoughts on the show but this
is what the cast has to say about the
series's end that's right Millie Bobby
Brown wants 11 to die in season five can
you imagine how sad would that be I know
it would be sad I know but that might be
part of the reason why Millie wants it
to happen she's like sacrifices herself
a big sacrifice would be pretty cool to
see but even Millie admits it would just
be so cool but I know it's never going
to happen Billy will not be appearing in
any stranger things spin-offs that may
be coming because she says I'm just so
focused on Enola Holmes stranger things
we saw it we love it we have big hearts
but let's make more enolas although she
added that quote I'd love to see another
bald-headed 10 year old get given that
opportunity I would help her now
navigated how sweet is that but end of
the day Millie says that quote I'm very
ready to say goodbye to this chapter of
my life and open new ones up although
we're sure that co-stars like Finn
wolfhard will always hold a special
place in her heart Finn wolfhard sees
the end of stranger things as something
of a graduation and we can see what he
means by that we've pretty much watched
him grow up on the show and he's had
plenty of on-screen firsts my first uh
like on-screen kiss was with Millie
although we're still waiting for Maya
Hawk to get her on-screen romance yeah I
think I know what you mean but as Finn
pointed out quote a lot of the same crew
has been working on the show since the
first season so it's gonna be amazing
and pretty heavy but really fun always
and as much as we're sure that's going
to be true Finn has also said I've tried
not to think about it or process how sad
it's going to be that definitely sounds
a bit like a graduation having recently
become a part of PlayStation Playmakers
Finn couldn't resist making the joke
that he'd have more time for game gaming
after filming was over saying quote
there's an insane amount that I haven't
played in the last little while would
you like to see Robin with a girlfriend
in season 5 Maya Hawk isn't sure I don't
I don't know I feel mixed about it on
the one hand she can see how that would
be great for Robin but at the same time
I also love characters where their love
life is not the center of their
existence so who would Maya like to see
Robin with if she isn't going to have a
romance this season and that friendship
with
um Steve is so special that's right
Steve Maya says that friendships are
really important and they deserve their
air time and friendships have been
carrying through me through my life and
if you'd like to be one of our friends
the best way you can do that is by
hitting that subscribe button but going
back to Maya for a bit she's guessing
that characters are going to die this
season and she said I would love to die
and get my heroes moment I'd love to Die
With Honor as any actor would but we're
just hoping Max gets to have a happy
ending poor Max had a tough time in
season four she ended this season in a
coma and so it's hard to say how much of
Sadie's sink will be seeing in season 5
which has to make the ending even harder
on her
I would like to I'd like to see her
awake Sadie said saying goodbye is going
to be awful these kids this entire cast
and crew it's family you can tell that
it's definitely taking its toll on Sadie
still she added quote it's scary and sad
but I think it's exciting to kind of
move on to the next chapter I guess
we're definitely excited to see what she
does next Sadie had to go places she'd
never gone as an actor for season four
and she did it easily saying I really
think about the character and especially
for a character like Max that I've been
with for a while it's easy for me to get
into that mindset and Sadie is far from
the only smart woman on set are you
excited to see more team-ups between
Nancy and Robin on season five Natalia
Dyer sure is she says that Nancy and
Robin have a really fun Dynamic and
they're so different but they're both
very smart women we love that and as
much as she's right when she says that
we love to see it as an audience we're
just glad to hear Natalia add that we
love to play it as actresses there's
there's uh there's some Nancy Robin
stuff going on season which I know I was
very excited to see that Natalia has
found a close friend in Maya on set
describing her as talented and funny
before going on to call her just such a
gift to be able to work with but we know
what you're wondering who's Nancy going
to end up with by the end of season five
Jonathan or Steve Well Natalia's been
pretty tight-lipped when it comes to
which one she would prefer
I have options I guess no that's no
guess we'll have to wait to find out and
in the meantime Noah schnapp needed to
be reminded that there was even going to
be a season five Noah schnapp was
devastated to hear about the end of the
show it's really crazy I mean I grew up
on the show he first got the news after
reading a letter The Duffer Brothers
posted and he had no idea anything was
happening beforehand because as he says
because they don't really tell us
anything because they know I'm always
spoiling stuff the news came as a bit of
a blow to the young actor and I and I
read it and I was just bawling I was so
upset he immediately texted his good
friend Millie it was like she was like
you're crying too like so am I after
that Millie texted Gayton Matarazzo and
he was like I'm crying too the emotional
actors got together to text The Duffer
Brothers to tell them like this is so
sad like I can't believe this is over
but the brothers weren't quite as
sentimental as our young cast texting
back you guys got to stop texting us
like I I know it's over but but we have
time left we understand why nobody
thought to text Joseph Quinn considering
Eddie died last season but that doesn't
mean he can't come back what do you
think will Eddie find a way to come back
for season five Joseph Quinn thinks it's
possible he said that quote me and Joe
Kiri were discussing ways in which I
could kind of return maybe I'd be like a
figment of gayton's imagination or
something how cool would something like
that be Joseph said that probably our
best bet for seeing any return would be
something a bit Supernatural but he even
said that quote my suspicion is that
Eddie has done what he needed to do for
The Duffer brothers Joseph would love to
come back for season five saying that
Eddie is great fun to play and they're
great people to play with but it feels
like his story's been told Joseph was a
big fan of the way that Eddie ended
season 4 as a hero calling his story a
beautiful exploration of redemption and
that's definitely a theme for the show
considering we can see that redemption
in the character of Hopper 2. when David
Harbor first started stranger things he
never wanted it to end he said quote
that's why I love the show I think it's
a great show even if I wasn't in it but
now that nine years have passed since he
first started filming he said I think
it's time for it to end David even went
so far as to say I don't want it to
become like other shows which are great
shows but like walking dead or Game of
Thrones where you continue to spiral out
of the story just to create content that
won't be happening with stranger things
you can feel safe knowing that David
promises quote that there's an end to
the story and I know that there's an end
for all of these characters and I'm
happy about that hopefully that's a sign
find that the ending is a happy one too
one where they successfully defeat the
villainous vechna but no matter how the
characters turn out for David he says
this ending is Bittersweet but it's
definitely time how terrifying was
vechna in season four Jamie Campbell
Bower has agreed to return in season
five and he says as far as I'm concerned
vechna ain't finished he's already
responsible for putting Max in a coma at
the end of the last season but as Jaime
said quote there's a lot more he needs
to do 11 is still out there she's one of
his main targets and that isn't all
Jaime wants you to pay special attention
to the moment where will on the show
says in Hawkins
I can feel him Jamie says I think
there's a connection there and I would
be interested to see if that's explored
in season five poor Jamie already went
through a lot when he was filming for
season four which required him to sit
still for seven and a half hours while
they applied makeup and Prosthetics we
imagine season 5 will require something
similar from him and yet he's still
excited to be reunited with co-stars
like Caleb McLaughlin
David Harbor isn't alone in thinking
that the show is ending at the right
time Caleb McLaughlin agreed with him
when he said it's sad but I think it
makes sense you don't want to over Milk
The Cow
still you can tell he's eager for season
five Caleb said that he and his co-stars
would quote reach out to each other once
in a while just to check in and talk
about quote hey I can't wait to see you
when we get back to Atlanta and start
filming anything did you guys read
anything did you hear anything yet but
as close as Caleb is with his co-stars
there is one person he probably won't be
working with much on season five can you
guess who it isn't geyton Matarazzo
though we'll be discussing him soon
we'll give you a hint who do you think
is the worst for breaking character and
laughing on set it's either me or
Charlie that's right it's Caleb and
Charlie Heaton and when the two of them
get together together
it's done Keaton is definitely going to
miss working on Stranger Things it's the
defining uh aspect of the past 10 years
of my life and that may actually be for
more reasons than one not only has it
been amazing but it's been like a pretty
great job security but considering
Gayton has already been cast in theater
Productions like Sweeney Todd we don't
think he has much to worry about some
fans have even been wondering if Gayton
is eyeing a role in the spin-off stage
play Stranger Things the first Shadow
but he says quote that might be too meta
although you may be able to catch him in
the play's audience when it comes to
Dustin's role in season five Gayton says
he hopes to see him get quote a bit of
an ego check he knows how smart he is
and at least from season four he's
learned how valuable he can be not just
to his friend group but to the
collective effort of stopping this
Supernatural threat I'd like to see him
be knocked down a few pegs whether they
already have their next role lined up
like Millie Bobby Brown or they're
afraid to lose that job security like
poor Gayton one thing is for sure you
haven't seen the last of this cast which
actor's thoughts were you most surprised
to hear we love to hear what you think
so make sure to let us know down in the
comment section